hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one very
interesting feature of Aristophanes
speech about love in the symposium is
his contrast between our original state
and the state that we currently inhabit
that what we take to be our normal state
he's telling us that if we understand
something about the kind of beings we
originally were this is allegorical of
course he's not making a historical
factual statement or a statement about
human you know Philo Genesis or anything
like that but if we understand that our
primal condition that will illuminate
the condition that we find ourselves in
today so what was our original state
we've already talked about you know
having the four arms and four legs and
getting cut down the middle and the
desire for unification that comes about
another feature of this is he says we
think in terms of two sexes and then we
talked about the different possible you
know permutations of relationships
between those when really we were
originally three sexes or three another
word for it would be races Guinea in
this and humankind you know we were a
little bit mixed up when we think about
our current situation and try to make
sense of it in terms
whether you're male or female because
the males and females were originally
parts of larger holes so he's got this
interesting origin story where you know
one class comes from the Sun and one
class comes from the earth and one class
comes from the moon which is kind of a
mixture of Sun and earth and we don't
really need to worry so much about the
astrological discussions there what's
really much more interesting and more
important for this is that the the
creature is coming from the Sun are
entirely male these are the ones that in
addition to their two faces and - you
know sets of arms and legs or what we
would consider two sets of arms and legs
they would consider a full set of arms
and legs they have two sets of male
genitalia so when they're split down the
middle what we get are two males which
doesn't feel the force of erotic
attraction towards each other
ideally towards the one that they're
missing but you know as I pointed out
before other males will do particularly
if they're close to the type of the one
that happens to be missing that's the
force of erotic desire what it was
really being desired is not just sex but
but also companionship and intimacy
there's a wonderful quote that I'll read
in just a moment and and what's really
being desired there is this restoration
of lost unity in the originally fully
male and Aristophanes is saying these
two males aren't really totally male
they're more male by the way for him
than the one over here but what was
truly male is is this original being
with with the full complement of bits
and pieces likewise we have beings that
are entirely female and when they're
split in half there you get two female
halves the same conditions hold they
feel erotic desire towards each other
they are looking again for their other
missing half
but if they can't find that particular
female missing half they will find
another female to be the object of their
desire and their affection its sexual
attraction you know intimacy and
hopefully some sort of restored fusion
now over here we have the androgynous
ones and he uses that word on Dragoon a
Andris means male or a man on air i
under oath read GU Niang means means
woman female and so the androgynous are
the ones who have one set of female
organs and one set of male organs when
they're split down the middle
you get one female half and one male
half again they feel erotic desire
towards each other they want to have sex
they want to have intimacy they want to
have companionship with the ultimately
desire is this fusion and the same sort
of thing holds we're you know if the
female half dies the male can seek out
another female half or vice versa won't
be quite the same as the original unity
but it allow these be some sort of
substitute for it here's what's
particularly interesting about this I
pointed out that the the male on this
side from the perspective of
Aristophanes is not as male as these
males are over here the female on this
side is not as female as the ones that
came from the original female so he's
saying that same-sex couples same-sex
attraction in a certain respect
expresses the essence of the gender more
than does other sexes hetero sexual
attraction and relationships very you
know an interesting point for him to be
making particularly since he's the only
person there who does not have a male
male relationship love relationship in
the symposium now he also gives some
actions of these and the descriptions I
think are quite interesting to provoke a
little bit of thought he says going back
to the androgynous one the man who is a
slice of the androgynous one will
naturally be attracted by women and then
he gives us an example the adulterer so
you know he's playing around with this
the force of erotic desire in this case
will lead to not actually forming a
attachment that is you know unique
monogamous you know marked by fidelity
he talks about the adulterer the one
who's seducing other people's wives and
then he talks about the woman who runs
after men you know the same side right
there's something about this androgynous
original sexuality that we call
heterosexuality that leads to a tendency
towards promiscuity on the part of both
sexes at least the way that that
Aristophanes is telling the story the
the possibility for more stable bonds
seems to be in these two so he talks
about you know the woman who is a slice
of the original females attracted by
women in fact she is a lesbian men who
are slices of the mail or followers of
the mail and show their masculinity
throughout their boyhood by the way they
make friends with men and the delight
they take in lying beside them and being
taken in their arms and then he says and
these are the most hopeful of the
nation's youth for theirs is the most
virile the most manly Constitution
because they came from the original man
now notice that you require this group
over here in order to continue the human
race in order to keep adding people to
it but Aristophanes is the way that he's
telling the story you know happiness can
arise for anybody in finding their
missing mate but he seems to be placing
it more on this side doesn't he as we as
we look through it he's not going to
talk quite so much about female female
relations he is going to talk quite a
bit more about male male relations but
I'm reserving that for another video the
key point here is that
yeah this we might say dividing by that
we can draw between the original or
primal nature of human beings which
gives us indications about how to
understand what we in fact experience in
our current condition and what we try to
make sense of by classifying so
Aristophanes is suggesting that the
classifications that we tend to make
might in fact have a basis that's not
really adequate to this original or
primal situation of human beings